the Board of Governors the Academy has  now voted an honorary Oscar for the best  performance they've not voted an  honorary Oscar for the best performance  by juveniles since 1954 when I almost  wanted this year now that I'm not  eligible they voted another one to  present it here is the first recipient  of this award captain of the good ship  lollipop miss Shirley Temple  Oh surely matter  you cut your curls well I guess he's  forgotten I'm the same age as Oscar  certain actors are very shrewd about  providing for the future charles boy a  invest in real estate fred macmurray  buys cattle and john mills has daughters  the academy tonight presents an Oscar to  a young girl who was brought Grace and  talent to the screen the star of  Pollyanna MS Hayley Mills  because Haley is in England working  tonight her award will be accepted by  Annette Funicello  on behalf of Hayley Mills and Walt  Disney thank you very much thank you  you